[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Nikki limo I'm 33 years old and
I've never had a slumber party so these
are my friends and they're gonna show me
what I've been missing out on all these
years I have a 12 year old son I've been
building forts for the last decade I'm
gonna teach Nicky exactly what to do
gathering supplies yeah we meet here put
that on your corner Jess can I just sit
in the back and get drunk
no okay the fort has been built no she
doesn't really know what she's doing so
we're just gonna do a stereotypical
sleepover stuff I'm like genuinely
excited really did you say never
obviously well forever no over at
friends houses before but not like in a
group environment not like oh wait the
slumber party I was not to say I felt
like I never had room for you there but
it's just people didn't come to my house
Oh people definitely don't come in my
house yeah I live in an apartment if you
look at y'all I never my best friend
that's it and I don't have like a
slumber party I never got a chance
because my parents are Asian and they
don't let me leave the house or have
friends over oh my god oh my god
I'm glad I'm not crazy or alone I feel
not alone all right
I'm an expert in this I had two best
friends when I was like 13 brag about it
I got a bunch of sweet lovers but DDR
and like we say no dude we say a lot
it's alone I dance dance revelution I go
to eat at a mummy - DDR and I lost 20
pounds oh my god when I played DDR I
used to play on them on my tippy-toes
so my calves were they were [ __ ] huge
because I would pay for place like three
or four hours a day like morning and
night yeah okay for this this sleepover
we're gonna play choose a dad well we're
gonna do a millennial style we're gonna
play some people may have heard of it
well we're not really playing we're just
taking the cards from Bearpaw another
YouTube channel and they basically do
more of a beer pong style thing where
when you pick up a cup you have to do
one of the dares in the back we're just
gonna do some dares with each other
because it is a sleepover and we
Plus these ones are kind of mean and if
I write them then it's my fault but if I
don't write them it's not a whole hey
son you read me about taking credit for
you absolutely so Nikki's gonna go first
oh all right
dip your socks in toilet water and wear
them for the rest what the [ __ ] do weird
stuff at sleepovers I'm glad I never had
a sleepover alone like forever
I didn't write it thank you watch guys
wait I thought it was true there dear so
if you don't do the do you how true
truth or dare
where's the truth take the truth [ __ ]
okay all right the truth anything you
want to ask me both okay
Nikki who's your favorite member of JK
man whoa Steve green but I'll give it to
her but no toilet water sucks
Nikki you choose hide Jared all right if
huh me yes okay do a celebrity
impression you can't stop until somebody
guesses who you are I know you love
doing impressions okay what do you mean
Hey
God that was awesome this is going to be
a 30 minute video sorry
Bozeman feel like I'm being bullied it's
terrible oh my oh you chose the e-book
your idea to like the nearest fuzzy
object you know get it [ __ ] rug this
one's closer no [ __ ] fuzz you have to
look it I just washed it before your
movie just a little bit I want a full
tongue drag me cringe just like any
about its you son mom but like the
texture I'll trade you I'll trade you
toilet socks bring me that
[Laughter]
I see how bullying works now yeah you
like sleepovers now hot Nikki [ __ ] by
Gatorade I wrote your next of that oh
that was very pointed okay oh but you
didn't need to let it like melt a little
bit okay wait okay
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
always just like punch each other no
I'll take my yellow I'm glad no corsets
and wet down uncomfortable describe the
last time you had sex
give the where who and the why tricky
for me because I don't know if any one
who's gonna watch this video who's got
this card it wouldn't be that juicy your
single friends so the where is in West
Hollywood he's straight though by the
way he has an apartment it was Hollywood
he's a straight man okay that doesn't
narrow in his apartment but we're in his
apartment on the couch oh my god why
would have to be like kind of like
famous and have things like recorded cuz
now guys are gonna know I can't get away
with being a ho okay
so he has an l-shaped couch and a bunch
of plants and like floor-to-ceiling
window okay the couch is tan but also it
hasn't issue that I think it's a down
couch because feathers are popping out
of the couch it's like a corporate
apartment it's really really nice except
the couch happens to have a couple it's
like a down we know different things do
you know because I want to know like
where on the couch position question
like I think that your legs were like
the way the couch so the chaise side of
the L couch is the Lord is like a very
wide it's like a very deep and wide
couch what was he into foreplay voice
well one thing you don't like is he's
very good with his fingers I know you
don't like I know you don't like that um
yeah we made out he made out in multiple
ways
touken yes so he did choke me can I said
to him I said I don't know if you're
gonna kill me he goes that's part of the
fun yeah like I did it all that's why I
did it on the down ass [ __ ] stupid
nasty couch if you die I can just roll
it up okay in design room sleepover
style we can't just do one thing God do
multiple things we haven't told Nicky
this yet we're gonna stiff as a board
oh hell no yeah I want to know what that
is oh did you ever watch demoness there
might be some young uns out here do they
know where this came from the movie the
craft
oh it's been around for why around for a
long time that's the first time I ever
saw wait we should try to levitate Nicky
though and say hmm I think that'll be
funnier mm-hmm can I hold my seat
we're gonna be playing light as a
feather stiff as a board
so let us finish this board is kind of
like a typical like 90s 2000 sleepover
game but it originally had in the 1600s
supposed to be some game yeah the crafts
populated it and it's basically what
we're gonna do is we're gonna try to
levitate Nicky but I I think I did this
one time as a kid so I had to look up a
guy and we're just gonna follow yeah so
this is some demonic [ __ ] yes some oh my
god weirder step one maybe the symbol
lights candles flashlights whatever okay
we ready did that Oh God imagine the
sprinklers went off right now oh I would
not be surprised okay step two have one
person lay down flat on the floor arms
crossed over their chest
as if
dead Oh arms crossed you know I was born
on day of the dead maybe put that like
in her vagina
it's gonna burn so Gina's got the ice
vagina and how you could know like we
already see yeah yeah put it out just
you can hold like a cigarette
two people sit on either side yeah and
well well if the fifth person is there
perfect like I'm dead yeah keep your
eyes closed for this part of it it will
handle everything from here start by
having everyone place two fingers one
each hand under the person laying in the
center and then go ahead and try to lift
them while they're completely conscious
it'll be near impossible okay so wait
let's oh wait wait two fingers each yeah
so Schultz of shoulders on our side and
then you guys okay okay ready and don't
we say something no this is just a
promote okay so one person is the group
leader this person will then tell the
story of how the individual in the
center is about to allow the spirit of
the dead person into their body simply
becoming corpse life and their leader
should instruct the body in the center
to slowly become stiff like a corpse and
because their body is here are now open
to supernatural influences and outsides
weird will enter and allow the body to
come what I like Jesus okay
I like saw so
rather citizen gradually the other
people start repeating alright so we
started you started okay I can do this
no no I'll do this way okay so um
spirits we allow you to enter the body
[Music]
okay spirits we allow you to enter the
body of Nikki limo forevermore spirits
we allow you to say ignore this age it
cannot protect her but this age
ignore the stage spirits we allow you to
enter the body of leading to the
condition like dude relax
Nikki she is stiff as a board yeah no
your little Ted stop [ __ ] okay all
right okay
everyone close your eyes I'll lead and
then follow with me okay and on the on
the sixth iteration will be into it
so what once I say it six times so I'll
say the first time and then you guys are
trying to yeah light as a feather stiff
as a board light as a feather stiff as a
board
stiff as a board light as opposed to
support light as a feather
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
okay so now I feel like we conjured
something and it's just like started we
could do bloody no no okay well it
didn't work soon you can't no so they're
like Nazis [ __ ] put her [ __ ] in the
toilet
well I did want to love it I just didn't
want to
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]